[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 11 octobre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
les titres de l'actualité yvelinoise le
front commun des présidents des sept
départements franciliens
hier il donnait une conférence de presse
pour faire entendre leur voix sur le
futur de la métropole du grand paris
cette collectivité regroupant 130 villes
de la région et que le gouvernement
pourrait renforcer
nous étions sur place les rencontres de
la sécurité se déroule jusqu'à samedi
elles ont pour objectif de faire
connaître aux français leurs
professionnels
une matinée était organisée à la
préfecture des yvelines est un village
sécurité routière se tiendra lui samedi
à voisins le bretonneux invités de cette
édition jean michel chevalier maire
adjoint de la commune
et puis à la fin de ce journal nous
partons dans la forêt de rambouillet
pour découvrir le brame ce cri si
caractéristique du cerf que l'on peut
entendre pendant la saison des amours
le message se voulait fort les sept
présidents de départements des
départements d'île de france se sont
réunis hier pour évoquer l'avenir de la
métropole du grand paris alors que les
rumeurs s'intensifient sur le sujet et
que le gouvernement prévoit de faire des
annonces importantes d'ici un mois les
précisions de nicolas kirillovitch c'est
une image inhabituelle de la politique
francilienne les sept présidents des
départements de la région assis côte à
côte pour évoquer ensemble un souci
commun la métropole du grand paris ce
nouvel échelon territorial créée il ya
18 mois qu'ils soient des républicains
socialistes ou communistes
ils veulent tous modifier le schéma de
la métropole une collectivité qu'il
estime néfaste pour les habitants de la
grande couronne exclus du périmètre
actuel en 2017 dans la république
française on veut faire un mur entre la
métropole riche la métropole riches pour
les riches
et puis la grande couronne qui l a tous
les ennuis c'est compliqué de venir à
paris en voiture
c'est compliqué de venir à paris un
transport en commun on se déplace pas ce
qu'on va chercher de l'emploi
nous avons une ambition plus grande
pourquoi parce que nous estimons que
c'est le bon échelon la région métropole
non seulement pour traiter les problèmes
de vie quotidienne de nos habitants mais
aussi dans la compétition internationale
pour faire face au grand londres plus
grandes et plus puissantes pour les
départements de la grande couronne moins
envahissante pour ceux de la petite
couronne val-de-marne hauts-de-seine et
seine-saint-denis et s'inquiète eu des
rumeurs concernant une suppression de
l'échelon départemental au profit de la
métropole
les projets je mets en oeuvre
aujourd'hui je le fais sur la base d'un
mandat démocratique qui m'a été confié
par les habitants de la
seine-saint-denis que chacun de ceux qui
ce faire plus gros et bien fasse la
démonstration de ce soutien démocratique
ce n'est pas le cas je suis favorable à
une grande métropole à caractère
stratégique c'est-à-dire qu'ils
travaillent à l'attractivité de la
région parisienne dans son ensemble au
plan international mais pas parce que la
métropole du grand paris s'occupe du
ramassage des ordures ménagères de la
gestion des crèches de des pmi
directement mis en cause l'exécutif
prévoit d'organiser début novembre une
conférence autour de l'avenir de la
métropole du grand paris est d'ici là
les tensions elles pourraient continuer
de s'accroître et pour être complet sur
cette actualité pierre bédier président
du conseil départemental des yvelines a
confirmé l'impossibilité pour le 78e 92
de fusionner si la métropole du grand
paris reste dans ses frontières
actuelles et d'ailleurs pour continuer à
se faire entendre plusieurs départements
franciliens organise mardi prochain à
versailles une réunion publique en
présence du président du sénat gérard
larcher
un nouveau patron pour l' agence
d'ingénierie philippe benassaya vient
d'être élu président de la structure
le maire et conseiller à départementale
l air de bois d'arcy succède à alain
schmitz tout nouveau sénateur
lancée en 2014 ingéniérie apporte un
soutien technique aux communes et
intercommunalités rurales des yvelines
le but réaliser des projets
d'investissement dans les meilleures
conditions économiques et financières
dans l'actualité du jour aussi les
rencontres de la sécurité c'est un
événement national organisé jusqu'à
samedi par l'état auxquels a pris part
également le département des yvelines la
préfecture à versailles organisé en son
sein une matinée les pompiers gendarmes
et policiers du territoire rencontrer
des étudiants pour présenter leurs
actions sur le terrain nick allen
l'hydro sa radio elle est là
et en fait sur le casse turin fils tu
branches ici ce mercredi matin la
préfecture de versailles l'agente ann
motards dans la police nationale sur le
département depuis deux ans joue les
professeurs lors de sa première
rencontre de la sécurité en tant
qu'animateur le gardien de la paix
présente ses missions et surtout son
deux roues devant un public assidu
j'avais les mêmes questions fassois de
questions d'ordre général sur la police
est spécifiquement sur les sur les motos
si ça suscite des vocations
pourquoi ben arfa soit les garçons les
filles au revoir la réaction de la
centaine de collégiens et de lycéens
présents ce jour là il se pourrait que
certains en fils dans les prochaines
années l'uniforme
on veut savoir
un peu les coulisses du métier de
gendarme parce qu'on les voit beaucoup
mais pas hors travail quoi je trouve ça
un peu un terrain un peu quand même
intéressant parce que
c'est quand même eux qui assurent notre
sécurité surtout qu'on est en vigipirate
au parallèle de cet atelier moto les
enfants ont pu découvrir une dizaine de
stands sur les pompiers la gendarmerie
encore la police criminelle
les démonstrations d'une quinzaine de
minutes avec des chiens renifleurs de
drogue étaient également au programme et
il est en train de chercher des
stupéfiants apparemment il a trouvé
c'est impressionnant sa mâchoire ça fait
un peu de la pub pour la police et enfin
la police peut retrouver après la drogue
nos drogues qui est caché pour les
étudiants la matinée s'est terminée par
une démonstration des techniques de la
brigade équestre hesdinoise pendant les
matchs où les manifestations
les rencontres de la sécurité se
poursuivent dans toute la france jusqu'à
ce samedi 14 octobre
chaque année deux cent mille personnes
participent à cet événement et au delà
de l'état des communes haussier
organisent leur événement sécurité c'est
le cas de voisins-le-bretonneux qui
propose samedi le village sécurité
routière c'est de 10 heures à 17 heures
à la cour de l'espace 2 coville sur le
parking de la poste est aussi au jardin
eugène fleurait bon soir jean michel
chevalier bon son vélo ries maire
adjoint de voisins-le-bretonneux vous
êtes délégué à la sécurité et au
patrimoine pourquoi dédier une journée à
présent le bretonneux une journée dédiée
à la sécurité routière
d'abord parce que c'est un sujet de
préoccupation en ce qui concerne
d'autres communes
il se trouve que sur voisins on est à la
croisée d'un triple trafic
d'abord le trafic interne à la commune
et ça c'est dans toutes les villes mais
on a en plus à un trafic de destination
puisque on accueille de plus en plus
d'entreprises sur le territoire
notamment la zone de la grande île où le
val saint quentin on a des grosses
sociétés comme europcar nissan ou
asmodée et on a un trafic de destination
gens qui n'habitent pas voisins mais qui
viennent travailler à voisins et puis le
troisième type de trafic qui est
probablement aujourd'hui le plus
pénalisant
c'est le trafic de transit c'est à dire
que ce sont des gens essentiellement de
la vallée de chevreuse qui traverse
voisins pour aller travailler sur les
autres d'emploi des yvelines et là
effectivement on a aujourd'hui voilà
beaucoup de bouchons beaucoup de
remontées de files et moi je me trouve
que ça provoque des comportements un
petit peu d'evian puisque aujourd'hui
notamment avec les gps collaboratif
on vous explique comment passer coûte
que coûte
ah oui clairement on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec des résidences ou des
zones pavillonnaires qui sont devenus
des axes de transit quotidien où on
passe devant des écoles à 8 heures de
rentrée le matin voilà donc on a le
sentiment que ça génère un petit peu
d'insécurité alors voir on a voulu
sensibiliser un petit peu tous les vices
chinois mais pas que lorsque c'est une
journée qui n'est pas réservé aux vies
si noah ces importantes saisies revers à
tout le monde c'est absolument ouvert à
tout le monde
il n'y a absolument aucune condition de
résidence sur le territoire de la
commune accord les ateliers sont
entièrement gratuits je tiens à le
préciser aussi c'est important on va
détailler d'ailleurs le programme dans
un instant les principaux les
principales animations au programme
aille on parlera de ça dans un instant
d'accord alors les chiffres des morts
sur les routes ont augmenté 1 depuis l
an passé dans les yvelines en août
depuis le début de l'année vingt
personnes avaient trouvé la mort dans un
accident contre 11 l'an passé il est
primordial ou est de sensibiliser sur ce
sujet des plus jeune âge c'est un sujet
qui préoccupe aussi un voisin
ah oui clairement c'est toujours un
drame un accident n'ont donc
effectivement il ya un vrai travail qui
est mené alors notamment par d'autres
polices municipales qui intervient dès
le plus jeune âge
cm1 cm2 avec l'instauration du permis
piéton du permis cycliste
les élèves sont ensuite accompagné en
sixième en cinquième aux notamment au
travers des itinéraires qu'ils vont
utiliser l'année d'après pour se rendre
au collège c'est un changement important
un de passer effectivement d'école
primaire au collège et puis encore une
fois par rapport à ce que je disais tout
à l'heure pour se rendre au collège on
va plus loin on se retrouve à traverser
des axes majeurs qui sont les axes
traversée par le trafic de transit
et là il faut effectivement sensibiliser
alors les plus jeunes les enfants bien
évidemment mais les parents aussi les
adultes exactement voilà d'où l'intérêt
de cette journée de samedi où on va
avoir à la fois des ateliers pour les
jeunes pour les enfants et des ateliers
pour les adultes vous avez parlé de la
police municipale y aura de nombreux
acteurs de la sécurité routière qui
seront présents pour ce village sécurité
routière au delà de la police municipale
qui sera présent sur sur ce village
alors c'est un vrai travail de
collaboration je profite d'être sur
votre plateau pour le souligner et
remercié les acteurs qui se sont
mobilisés notamment la police nationale
au travers du majeur d'être co qui nous
a beaucoup accompagné sur ce projet et
les pompiers le sdiss 78 au travers du
chef de groupe en sus d'un colonel 12
il y aura des ateliers police municipale
il y aura des ateliers police nationale
la police nationale sera présente avec
des motards avec des systèmes de mesure
de vitesse jumelles des systèmes de
vision par lunettes qui simulent les
état alcoolique
les états d'utilisation de drogue et
puis tout un tas de partenaires la pf
association des paralysés de france qui
va réaliser des parcours en profite
aussi pour sensibiliser au problème du
handicap resteras dans le jardin c'est
ça exactement le j'aime rire est
exactement des parcours vélo pour les
enfants mais aussi pour les adultes il
ya la présentation de vélos électriques
parce que travailler sur la sécurité
routière et sur la congestion des flux
c'est aussi travailler j'étais à la part
des déchets du vélo exactement des
bonnes actif ce qu'on disait les modes
doux et maintenance et les modes actifs
donc il y aura aussi des ateliers
relatifs à ça je disais tout à l'heure
des simulateurs simulateur de conduite
de deux roues simulateur de conduite
voiture voiture tonneau et tu retournes
aux essarts est classique dans le genre
d'événement rectum en fin de compte de
l'importance de la ceinture de sécurité
oui c'est tout à fait ludique mais c'est
important vous faites bien de le
rappeler une grande manifestation à 15
heures une démonstration alors sous
réserve que les moyens soient
disponibles parce que il faut mobiliser
des moyens importants mais on a convenu
avec le groupement sud 12 10 78 de
réaliser un exercice en direct de zinc
de désincarcération donc d'intervention
du véhicule de secours routier d'un vs
avez d'accord dans la cour de covile ils
vont simuler effectivement une
intervention de désincarcération donc
c'est un des moments forts de la journée
voilà sous réserve toujours que le vsr
soient disponibles à ce moment là
puisque on utilise des moyens des moyens
actifs
ouais c'est ça dépend bien sûr des aléas
des journées il ya aussi alors vous
parliez des deux roues il y aura un
atelier de maniabilité du de moto c'est
si oui alors qu'ils étaient prévus à
l'origine avec un partenaire qui
malheureusement nous a fait faux bond
mais on vraiment un des participants et
je tiens à le remercier
un autre participant s'est substitué
nous a proposé une solution de repli qui
sera tout aussi avec qui va lentement
créé un atelier de prévu maniabilité de
roues sur le parking de la poste
l'objectif étant effectivement d'arriver
à anticiper un petit peu mieux les
contraintes de la conduite de scooter ou
de moto puisque c'est là encore un moyen
de transport très accents dit très
accidentogène pardon ce village sécurité
routière c'est donc samedi à voisins le
bretonneux
rendez vous de 10 heures à 17 heures et
pour plus d'infos sur cet événement vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site internet
de la commune qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci jean michel chevalier
d'avoir été avec nous je le rappelle
vous êtes maire adjoint de
voisins-le-bretonneux en charge
notamment de la sécurité
merci beaucoup elle est ouverte depuis
le 22 septembre à guyancourt l'épicerie
et lippi du rotois re a pris place dans
la boulangerie à pizzeria des petits
pains gourmand principe original proposé
par la sauce régal pouvoir acheter des
produits locaux et bio à des tarifs
intéressants en contrepartie il faut
donner un peu de son temps pour faire
tourner la boutique une trentaine
d'adhérents ont pour le moment à adopter
ce concept on voit ça avec nicolas
landry et aurélie ronze annan fait
partie des adhérents de l'association à
se régaler cela lui donne le droit de
venir faire ses courses à l'épi du
rotois re installé à guyancourt cette
épicerie participative propose plus de
90 produits
on a des produits de producteurs locaux
avec des produits
bon et sain on a vraiment là la
traçabilité du produit de la création à
la livraison est licite des sardines des
bières locales du miel ou encore des
conserves
tous les produits sont issus du circuit
court ce qui permet de les retrouver à
des tarifs avantageux
le principe est simple les adhérents
font leurs courses en ligne et viennent
les récupérer les mardis et vendredis
soir ainsi que le samedi matin
en échange ils doivent donner deux
heures de leur temps par mois il n'y a
pas un zéro n'y a pas d des chefs de
rayon où on est tous au même niveau
on va aller chacun notre tour ou qui se
dévouent pour aller chercher chez les
producteurs ou prendre contact pour
rechercher de nouveaux produits ou la
mise en rayon ou le réassort pour
l'instant 35 personnes ont adhéré à ce
concept dont l'objectif est également de
créer du lien social
le fait d'avoir une adhésion et de
former un groupe où chacun participe je
trouve que c'est très intéressant et que
ça crée du lien aussi au niveau du look
de du voisinage convivialité manger
mieux et pour moins cher voici les
valeurs défendues par les piqûres ou
thouars qui devrait bientôt enrichir le
concept santé la semaine du handicap se
poursuit à montigny le bretonneux 14e
édition pour mobiliser les énergies en
faveur de l'ouverture sur l'autre
un programme riche avec comme vous le
voyez en images une course relais
d'entreprise elle a rassemblé une
trentaine d'équipés hier en partenariat
avec un spécial olympix cette
association oeuvre pour l'épanouissement
par le sport des personnes atteintes
d'un handicap mental
autre événement phare vendredi un non
dit recrutement qui se déroulera à
l'hôtel de ville pour les personnes en
situation de handicap qui recherchent un
emploi
une quinzaine d'entreprises
saint-quentinoise présente rendez vous
de 9h à 12h santé toujours à partir de
lundi c'est la semaine de la colonne
vertébrale et pour la troisième année
consécutive l'association française de
chiropraxie se mobilisent pour
l'événement avec moi en plateau
stéphanie et belmont soir vous êtes
chiropracteur à bailly
les yvelines et vous participez donc à
cette semaine de la colonne vertébrale
on en parle dans un instant reprécisons
peut-être les choses d'abord la
chiropraxie ou chiropractie on peut dire
on peut dire les deux c'est une pratique
médicale à ses anciennes même si on la
connaît encore pas tout à fait en france
mais c'est une pratique mais qui est
très répandue aux états unis directement
c'est une thérapie manuelle qui est né
dans les années 1800 aux états unis qui
se développe de plus en plus en france
le but est de détecter et corriger et
prévenir les troubles neuro musculo
squelettiques
on les regroupe sur les formes tms le
plus connu en fait ces décès des
pathologies qui regroupe les tissus mous
les tissus mous c'est les ligaments les
muscles les nerfs et les tendons
elles sont liées généralement une
activité professionnelle d'accord faut
savoir que c'est quand même la maladie
professionnelle la plus répandue
d'accord elle se traduit en général par
une fatigabilité musculaire détention on
peut avoir des picotements des angles
doucement en fait on prend en charge
vraiment ce type de pathologie
généralement en cabinet et la
chiropraxie en france je lisais pas
totalement encore reconnu enfin elle est
reconnue officiellement ça fait un peu
plus de dix ans maintenant elle est
reconnue depuis 2002 d'accord exactement
a donc de plus en plus en fait de nous
sommes mis chiropracteur intervalles à
travers la france voilà pourquoi du coup
petit à petit on se fait connaître
voilà d'engouement rendre de plus en
plus et on envoie les gens qui ont connu
et connaissent de plus en plus sa
thérapie là et concrètement quelle
différence avec d'autres pratiques
médicales je pense par exemple à
l'ostéopathie ses complexes que sa porte
il ya des vrais résultats concrets oui
il ya des résultats et heureusement
d'ailleurs
heureusement d'ailleurs en fait c'est
des techniques ils sont totalement
différentes mais énormément basé sur le
système nerveux le système nerveux se
compose de votre moelle épinière bref
votre
vos nerfs en fait donc sort de cette
moelle épinière et à travers laquelle
circulent votre douleur quand vous avez
un souci généralement c'est au niveau
nerveux le but c'est chez nous c'est
d'essayer de comprendre d'où vient cette
douleur pour la lever et faire
disparaître aux douleurs du g10 vous
associer à vos confrères pour la journée
mondiale de la colonne vertébrale la
semaine c'est une journée mondiale qui à
partir de lundi et qui se prolongera
pour vous sur toute la semaine
quel est le but concret de cette semaine
pourquoi s'associe à vos confrères
alors en fait on répond normalement en
fait tout départ à un appel lancé par
une ong américaine dans les années 2000
qui voulaient visait en fait à prendre
conscience de l'importance d'avoir un
dos et des articulations en bonne santé
nous notre but en fait c'est donc c'est
d'avoir répondu à cet appel pour faire
prendre conscience à nos passions du
coup dur à porto soit effectivement de
se soigner dessus on va ouvrir nos
portes en fait pour offrir des bilans
verte est beau c'est à dire une analyste
de la posture ainsi que des
articulations du corps et pouvoir
délivrer des conseils aux patients afin
d'améliorer leur état général est les
problèmes de dos qui peuvent devenir un
véritable cauchemar
avec l'âge il existerait des moyens
efficaces pour pour les soigner pour les
presser oui oui il ya déjà presque
chaque chaque patient est différent
chaque chaque pathologie est différente
nous envisageons effectivement à travers
la balle à la une très large entre un
large éventail de façon de traiter pour
que du coup ça s'améliore et ce soit
surtout durables dans le temps se sait
ça ancien généralement que les passions
cherche c'est que ils viennent au
cabinet certes pour aller mieux il faut
surtout dans le temps ils puissent
prendre le relais et à les booking et ça
qu'on cherche sûrement ça peut être quel
type de technique vous allez utiliser ça
va dépendre et vous le disiez du patient
exactement en fait exactement nous on a
des techniques mécanique assistée on a
essayé effectivement des techniques
manuelles en fait ce sera quand même
qu'on est les seuls thérapeute nommer de
noms médecin a été habilité à pratiquer
des manucures et des manipulations
vertébrales sans avis médical
vous pouvez venir nous voir directement
en première intention et non en fonction
de chat de vous dire si ça rentre pas
dans notre arsenal thérapeutique et
ensuite pouvoir vous traitez pour
améliorer cela donc on pourra venir vous
voir lundi si ça se poursuivra sur tout
l'aspect exactement ce sera du 16 au 20
après c'est sûr vous rendez vous donc
n'hésitez pas à contacter les
chiropracteurs à travers la france parce
que tout le monde ouvre ses portes et
suivant les disponibilités on vous
accordera
un petit peu vous expliquer tout ça vous
le disiez aussi un bilan gratuit en
sachant qu'une séance ça coute combien
en moyenne alors un truc inventé 60
euros après du point etc
vous êtes installé c'est à dire de wade
de l'endroit où se situe le cabinet mais
en général cela tourne autour de 40 et
60 euros la la ces consultations le club
est donc question pratique pour terminer
on peut venir
il faut réserver ou et vous le disiez il
faut prendre rendez-vous pedessac de man
par téléphone
il ya certains confrères qui ont
exactement qui utilise aussi les sites
internet donc regarder avec eux ou sinon
n'hésitez pas à les contacter pour voir
directement avec eux par téléphone
on peut peut-être aussi vous joindre sur
le site internet qui s'affiche pour nos
téléspectateurs il nous reste une petite
une petite 35 30 secondes pardon pour
une dernière question une petite
dernière question qu'est ce que vous
attendez de cette semaine qu'est ce qui
ferait que ça serait une réussite pour
alors déjà nous de but premier c'est
effectivement de fourreaux faire
connaître notre thérapie en fait ce que
du coup comme on disait
nous ne sommes que 1000 chiropracteur
pour avoir un petit ratio il ya
vingt-cinq mille ostéopathe à peu près
ont forcément n'est pas on est beaucoup
moins connue la communication se fait
progressivement qui consacre de plus en
plus les gens commencent à connaître une
bonne semaine c'est effectivement des
patients qui vont venir ont pu prendre
conscience un petit peu tout cette
importance d'avoir un dos en bonne santé
et notre but il va être là c'est pour
leur délivrer les conseils pour que que
ça pour que s'améliorent en fait vous
êtes chiropracteur à bailly dans les
yvelines et vous participez à la semaine
de la colonne vertébrale c'est donc la
semaine prochaine de lundi à vendredi on
peut retrouver je disais tout à l'heure
un vos coordonnées sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran est le
week end dernier c'était la 24e édition
du festival de la bd à duke une
cinquantaine d'auteurs a fait le
déplacement au programme rencontre avec
les lecteurs dédicaces et dessins retour
sur l'événement avec camille lambert et
nicolas d'andrus tomtom est venu sans sa
soeur nana mais sa maman bernadette des
prix l'a accompagné au festival de bande
dessinée de buc le rendez-vous des
auteurs et de leurs héros avec les
lecteurs
ma fille que vous avez
et lors elle avait six ans et là tout de
suite rentré dans ses histoires
maintenant l âme à 46 alors je pense que
en effet les parents sont tous un peu
dans cette ligne là et que du coup il
communique un peu ça alors on sent aussi
béatrice qui dessine les tom tom et nana
quand j'étais tout petit j'en lisais
beaucoup et là je voulais faire
découvrir mes cousins et de rencontrer
rencontrer des personnes dont on
apprécie le travail d'échangé un petit
peu avec eux et bien sûr le dessin la
petite dédicace en bonus et jean a
obtenu la dédicace de jean claude
fournier connu pour avoir dessiné spirou
et fantasio entre les années 70 et 80
j'aime bien rencontrer mes lecteurs en
général c'est sympa j'aime bien
entretenir des rapports
amicaux avec les gens et puis on
rencontre les copains aussi parce que
bon on est très solitaire on a un métier
très solitaire donc là c'est l'occasion
de rencontrer les copains à suivre il ya
des fois au bout d'une centaine de
spirou dans la matinée je commence à
avoir un peu ras-le-bol et je propose au
jour d'autres choses mais là ce premier
temps à graulhet de son côté fabien est
venu spécialement pour jean pleyers avec
comme demande un portrait de louis je
suis très heureux de rencontrer parce
que c'est un très grand dessinateur
c'est aussi un très grand scénariste et
puis l'occasion de parler avec lui de
ces projets ou de ce qu'il a fait durant
sa carrière c'est très très présent au
total plus de 8000 visiteurs sont venus
parcourir les vignettes et remplir les
bulles de cette 24e édition du festival
de bd de buc un râle profond qui résonne
dans les bois pas de doute c'est bien la
saison des amours chez les serres pour
attirer les femelles et combattre ses
adversaires le roi de la forêt pousse
son brame si caractéristique à l'espace
rambouillet il est encore possible de
l'écouter lors de visites guidées
mais attention les stars ne sont pas
toujours très coopérative camille
lambert
le dernier portant sinon les acteurs une
immersion dans la nature à la rencontre
du roi de la forêt c'est grâce à l'oeil
aguerri d'ambroise graffin directeur de
l'espace rambouillet que les visiteurs
vont pouvoir approcher au plus près des
animaux cerfs chevreuils des sangliers
se promène dans cet espace de 180
hectares mais pour être sûr d écouter le
brame
il faut d'abord trouver les biches j'ai
vu de mal ils ont fait le tour et sont
revenus par là bas il y en a encore qui
sont là bas il en a tendance à se
regrouper à se rapprocher voire de biche
soit le au lever du soleil soit soit
crépuscule ou la nuit tombe
mais les recherches se poursuivent la
harde de biche fini par se deviner dans
la pénombre et si on a du bras
c'est à cet endroit là qui va se
concentrer le brame le fameux cri poussé
par le ser il sera pas pousse pousse et
uniquement par le cerf dominant la part
du temps en fait c'est un jeu
d'intimidation entre se sert des mines
ans et quelques serres qui sont autour
à 2,3 en général et qu'ils vont chercher
à lui piquer sa place
un cri qui marque aussi une volonté
d'accouplement mais ce soir les 25
animaux n'étaient pas très entreprenants
malgré plusieurs minutes d'attentes
ils sont restés silencieux à la
clairière ça nous a permis cette balade
de observer des animaux
dans une phase presque nocturne et qui
est un peu plus croustillantes
après il nous a manqué ce soir un petit
peu le sont donc le brame proprement dit
ça arrive il faut rester humble
devant la nature la période du brame
s'étend jusqu'à mi octobre avec un peu
de chance et beaucoup de patience encore
quelques jours pour en profiter
cette soirée à l'espace rambouillet
c'était aussi l'occasion pour l'office
national des forêts de sensibiliser à la
protection de l'environnement
l'organisation gère 8 % du territoire
national selon son directeur général le
siècle du béton et du métal est passé le
bois est désormais le matériau du futur
écoutez le au micro de camille lambert
le matériau bois à la fois dans la
construction dans le design et dans les
objets du quotidien présente et de
grande qualité en plus c'est une
matériau renouvelable tout à fait
disponible en france c'est un matériau
nous semble-t-il du futur est de plus en
plus d'architectes et de designers ont
compris compris de grands architectes
internationaux que c'est une nouvelle
voie enfin pendant tout le mois
d'octobre trouver votre service civique
yvelines information jeunesse organise
des services civiques dating rencontres
pour trouver une mission d'intérêt
général
prochain rendez vous demain à maurepas
c'est au café de la plage de 14h à 18h30
qu'est ce que le service civique et
quels secteurs concerne-t-il réponse
avec laurence cousin qui était notre
invité dans le journal du 28 septembre
dernier
on est sur un engagement volontaire pour
qui s'adresse à des jeunes entre 16 et
25 ans à voir des jeunes qui pas vers 30
ans y sont en situation de handicap qui
s'engagent sur une mission d'intérêt
général
et quel organisme peut proposer des
services civiques sur quels domaines on
peut faire son service civique
alors quel organisme des services de
l'état collectivités territoriales
fondations associations
j'en oublie peut-être en tout cas voilà
il ya de nombreux organismes qui peuvent
effectivement faire appel à des
volontaires du service civique à
l'entrée demain sera libre pour se
rendre sur place à maurepas des navettes
seront au départ de vélizy
villacoublay et de montigny le
bretonneux inscription au préalable
souhaité c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal il est disponible en replay
ainsi que les reportages sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
et 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]